okay let's bring in YF bandel he's
professor of political science and
international relations at Qatar
University thank you for joining the
program today what do you make of these
plans by the US to impose Visa bans on
Israeli settlers who engage in violence
on Palestinians do you think it will
have any teeth uh well I think it's a
first step in the right direction over
the last uh week or so we have seen a
shift in US position from uh giving the
Israelis the green light to do whatever
they want secondly proceed with caution
and make sure that international law is
upheld and now we saw a third uh step in
that direction
prosecut declining visas to sett who
engage in in criminal activities against
the Palestinians I don't think uh this
particular step will have any on the
ground because it will not change uh
change much not getting a Visa to go to
the United States is not necessarily the
end of the world and notably it doesn't
affect uh those Israeli settlers with US
passports who may be most affected uh
We've also had France uh call for
similar sort of sanctions uh from the
European Union do you believe there is a
a wider push now from the International
Community to really pressure Israel on
the War I think there is there has been
if we look at what has been happening
over the last we we we see that there
has been a shift in this position both
in the US and the European Union they
are turning up the heat on Israel at the
moment but uh but is what could they
actually do that would really hurt
Israel well there are lot of things that
could be done in theory in practice
whether they'll be done or not is a
completely different story in the United
States there will be presidential
elections in about 11 months uh from uh
from now and and I think that the the
American Administration will be very
very very careful looking at those
elections uh trying to make sure not to
upset
the the Jewish Lobby in the United
States there are so many uh things that
the United States and Europe can do in
uh Theory but in practice it will be uh
difficult at this stage to implement How
concerned are you about a wider
escalation in the region uh we've had
Iran backed houthi rebels in Yemen just
over the weekend striking commercial
vessels in the Red Sea we've also seen
more escalation on the Lebanon Israel
border is this just both sides you know
showing what they're capable of or is it
something much more serious well I think
I do not think that will be an
escalation or in the in the region
obviously the htis as well asah in
Lebanon have always had issues with
Israel they launched a few missiles and
so on and so forth in in order to show
support for the Palestinian resistance
but as long as the U big players in the
region namely Egypt uh Iran and also
turkey are not necessarily we hear
little a lot of noise from these
capitals but not nothing concrete so as
long as
these Regional powers are keeping quiet
I do not think it will escalate what do
you think the broad
strategy uh Israel's border strategy is
because there's not just the situation
in Gaza or their war in Gaza we've also
seen the escalation of violence and the
raids in the occupied West Bank I is
Hamas just the Target or is it much
wider than that I think Hamas is the
target uh on the surface because that's
what Netanyahu uh said his main aim is
to destroy Hamas completely uh and
obviously make sure that Gaza is no no
longer poses a threat on the state of
Israel but what has been happening in
the West Bank as far as the Israelis are
concerned they suggesting that we are
targeting those Hamas sympathizers and
so on and so forth but as far as I'm
concerned they're trying to create an
atmosphere of fear and intimidation to p
and total control of the Palestinians
also in the West Bank really good to get
your perspective Yousef bandel Professor
political science international
relations at Kata University thank you
thanks